Après deux mois d'absence
Et l'achat d'un micro qu'elle commence à
peine à maîtriser
Elle revient plus forte que jamais...
"Stop! T'as pas besoin de faire une intro
grandiloquente pour montrer que t'as enfin
guéri ta panne d'écriture.
-Mais j'voulais faire de jolis plans, avec
la cape et tout...
-Garde ta cape si tu veux, mais raconte nous
tes trucs historiques maintenant, on a assez
attendu!
-Ok...
Bonjour et bienvenue dans Chroniques de Prof,
j'espère que vous êtes bien réveillés
parce qu'on va parler des pictes.
-Les pictes?
-Les pictes.
-Et collégram.
Les pictes sont un peuple qui a probablement
vécut entre le IIIe et le IXe siècle, et
qui se trouvait à peu près là:
En Ecosse, en compagnie de tout un tas d'autres
peuples qui résistèrent encore et toujours
à l'envahisseur romain.
On les connaît en grande partie grâce à
la description qu'en font les romains, qui
sont confrontés à ce peuple lors de la conquête
de la Bretagne et finissent par bâtir un
mur entre la partie conquise et la partie
Nord du pays pour s'assurer qu'ils restent
bien chez eux.
Il s'agit du mur d'Hadrien, qui est complété
par le mur d'Antonin un peu plus au Nord.
Ce sont d'ailleurs les romains qui donnent
leur nom aux pictes: il s'agit d'un dérivé
de picti, qui signifie peint.
Ce nom fait référence aux peintures bleues
dont les pictes semblaient se recouvrir, et
qui sont reprises chaque fois qu'on voit un
picte au cinéma.
En réalité, il est possible qu'il ne s'agisse
pas de simples peintures de guerre mais de
tatouages, puisqu'un poète romain parle de
«dessins marqués au fer». Malheureusement
on ne connaîtra probablement jamais la vérité,
ni quelle forme prenaient ces tatouages.
Avant l'arrivée des romains, les pictes s'appelaient
les Prydyn, et peut-être avant ça les Priteni.
Ce qui pourrait aussi avoir donné le nom
latin Britanni, Breton.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, il y a beaucoup
d'hypothèses mais peu d'affirmations par
rapport à ce peuple.
On ignore, par exemple, quelle langue ils
parlaient, et s'il s'agissait d'une langue
celtique ou trouvant son origine ailleurs.
Du fait de leur hostilité face à l'arrivée
des romains, de leur mode de vie différent
et des peintures ou tatouages dont ils se
paraient, les romains les ont rapidement catalogués
comme un peuple barbare.
-Facile à dire, pour les romains un barbare
c'était quelqu'un qui n'était pas de culture
gréco-romaine.
-Si c'est comme ça je suis barbare et fière
de l'être.
-D'ailleurs il semblerait que les pictes aient
été le dernier peuple de Bretagne à se
tatouer le corps, ce qui pouvait être vu
comme un symbole de fierté et de résistance.
Quoi qu'il en soit, les représentations qu'on
conserve d'eux les montrent comme des hommes
assez sanguinaires, comme sur cette image
qui date du XVIIe siècle, ou encore celle-ci.
On retrouve souvent, dans leur représentation,
la présence d'armes, de tatouages qui ne
ressemblent pas au style de dessins retrouvés
sur les pierres ou les bijoux pictes et qui
ne sont donc probablement pas fidèles, et
éventuellement de têtes de victimes fraîchement
découpées parce qu'on n'a pas encore assez
insisté sur le fait qu'ils étaient de GROS
BARBARES.
-Tout le monde n'a pas l'air d'un barbare
en tenant une tête dans sa main.
Nous allons maintenant voir que la réalité
était un peu différente.
On sait déjà qu'ils pouvaient être de bons
artistes: ils nous ont laissé des pierres
représentant des formes géométriques ou
des symboles, des animaux...
Voire même des croix, le christianisme commençant
à se répandre dans les Highlands alors que
les pictes existent encore.
On a également retrouvé des bijoux, comme
cette broche par exemple.
Il semble qu'il ait existé plusieurs royaumes
pictes.
Bède le Vénérable, un moine qui écrit
au VIIIe siècle l'Histoire ecclésiastique
du peuple anglais, déclare qu'il existe deux
royaumes pictes du Nord et du Sud.
Il s'agissait probablement de sortes de clan,
et on sait que les pictes étaient matrilinéaires:
l'héritage, le droit du sang, était transmis
par la mère et non par le père.
Les royaumes n'étaient donc pas gouvernés
de père en fils mais passaient aux frères,
aux neveux ou aux cousins, selon les familles.
On a retrouvé au bord du loch Tay, en Ecosse,
des vestiges d'un bâtiment où vivaient des
pictes et qui nous a permis d'en savoir un
peu plus à leur sujet: en le reconstruisant
à l'identique, on a obtenu ceci: il s'agit
d'un crannog, dans lequel pouvait vivre une
communauté de 20 à 40 personnes.
On a également retrouvé dans le loch des
objets qui ne provenaient pas des environs,
et qui laissent supposer que ces pictes commerçaient
avec d'autres peuples.
Enfin, d'après les romains, ils étaient
aussi de bons marins.
Ce qui rend les pictes légendaires n'est
pas seulement le manque d'informations dont
on dispose sur eux, mais le fait qu'au IXe
siècle, en l'espace de quelques dizaines
d'années, ils aient totalement disparu.
On ne trouve plus de traces d'art picte au
delà du IXe siècle, et on ne peut que supposer
les raisons de cette disparition.
Tout au long de la période durant laquelle
ont vécut les pictes, ils n'étaient pas
seuls: ils coexistaient avec de nombreux
autres peuples, notamment les Bretons dans
le Sud, et les Gaels venus d'Irlande qui étaient
installés dans l'Ouest de l'Ecosse.
Les relations entre les pictes et les gaels
n'étaient pas très bonnes, comme en atteste
la présence de forteresses tournées vers
les terres pictes chez les gaels.
Ils avaient une culture totalement différente,
et les gaels sont christianisés dès le Vie
siècle.
C'est sur leurs terres que Saint Colomban
installe son premier monastère en 563, dans
l'espoir de christianiser le reste de l'Ecosse.
Il s'efforce notamment de convertir les pictes,
et il semble y parvenir puisqu'on observe
une évolution dans leurs représentations:
c'est flagrant avec cette pierre du VIIIe
ou IXe siècle, qui comporte un côté païen
et un côté chrétien.
-Pile ou face?
-Face.
-Pile, t'es convertie!
-Et meeerde...
-Cette diffusion du christianisme a pu permettre
à tous ces peuples d'Ecosse de s'aimer, ou
au moins de se supporter, dans le partage
d'une religion commune.
-C'est pourquoi les pictes disparaissent,
en se fondant dans les autres peuples existants.
Fin.
-Pas si vite! Il se passe d'autres choses,
puisque de nouveaux peuples entrent en jeu
et tentent d'envahir le territoire.
C'est le cas des Angles, qui dominent déjà
le reste de la Grande Bretagne et qui décident
de pousser au Nord, et des vikings dont je
vous ai déjà parlé dans ma précédente
vidéo.
-C'est comme ça que les pictes disparaissent,
en se faisant massacrer à coups de casques
à cornes.
Fin.
-Mais empêchez-la de dire n'importe quoi!
-Ha-ha, on voit que t'es nouvelle ici.
-Il est probable que des pictes aient été
massacrés.
Mais ces invasions forcent aussi les peuples
d'Ecosse à former des alliances plus resserrées.
Et c'est vers 840 qu'entre en jeu Kenneth
MacAlpin, qui devient roi de tous les pictes
et même des autres peuples (peut-être en
assassinant les autres rois en place, ou en
profitant du fait qu'ils aient tous été
tués par les vikings, on ne sait pas).
C'est une sorte de Vercingétorix écossais,
sauf que dans cette version de l'Histoire,
il gagne à la fin.
-Préviens quand tu spoiles!
-Il est le premier à parvenir à unifier
tous les peuples et à régner sur tous.
Ses successeurs continuent de régner sur
ce qu'on appelle Pictland, jusqu'à une période
de transition entre 878 et 889 où le terme
de Pictland disparaît au profit de Scotland.
L'Ecosse devient un royaume christianisé
et gaelique, la disparition des pictes ne
résulterait donc pas d'un massacre par un
autre peuple mais d'un phénomène de transformation
culturelle, qui rend peu à peu obsolètes
le langage, les pierres et les tatouages pictes.
C'est ainsi que Kenneth MacAlpin est considéré
dans le mythe écossais comme le Ier roi d'Ecosse,
mais c'est une autre Histoire...
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, il
a été un peu difficile à écrire déjà
parce que j'ai eu du mal à m'y mettre et
parce qu'il existe assez peu de sources sur
les pictes donc forcément certaines infos
se contredisent.
Mais j'ai été assez fascinée par ce peuple
à travers les films que j'ai vus qui les
représentaient, notamment le Roi Arthur,
et c'est ça qui m'a donné envie d'en savoir
plus sur qui ils étaient vraiment.
On se retrouvera bientôt pour un nouvel épisode,
et en attendant vous pouvez toujours me suggérer
des thèmes dans les commentaires, je prends
toutes les idées.
Ou presque.
A la prochaine!